hello welcome to this video playing
chromatic eat see car we said I'm Yvonne
Yvonne is which what kind of thing is
that ok so see 5 let's keep that porn
and instead of valid opening he's
sacrificing her porn early on here hmm
no idea let's take let's take it and ask
questions later get some compensation on
the light squares so it's not completely
bogus like t5 and so on if he takes
instilled football
hmm ok looks with strange to be honest
to put the Queen on that square where
you are I mean d 5 is the square that
gives you the potential compensation and
normally you would try to you know get
some some minor piece there then term
you didn't try for that at all ok so how
to do this now i can teach g5 ok i don't
know there should be six Bishop e7
community 726 returns the palm which is
a bit unambitious
hmm I should be six Bishop e7 Bishop b5
58 that's probably leading nowhere I
athletes nowhere okay let's play the
simple stuff yeah I'm just okay without
anything particularly special happening
that same could have done that quicker
it was
okay I just I just saw that yeah I'm a
ticking in that porn so things are not
super simple for him at school ever six
prevent 95 business I've got the D file
so I gather hmm I was more thinking
about the move that actually wanting to
play it but I don't think it's bad it's
a little bit a little bit too quick
let's think about this for a moment 94
is also move will take take be seven
though okay I think this is this is ok
95 i also have Bishop to g5 it's not
even thinking about it isn't this just
good for me I don't quite get it hmm our
team needed to do something something
different but um maybe I'm wrong I mean
this guy is ready a guide to 650 or
something so
so what are we doing here roped it
towards a bit lame huh check my probably
not bad
if a four is the move that is varying me
a little bit in terms of trying to do
for more than a draw in so there's some
way
probably not i don't see a way to play
this for winning some kind of meaningful
way
nope it's probably just the draw I don't
know why it's not going 8-4 I don't
quite get it maybe I just take and I
know I'm still better time morning ok
say anything else then taking now sure
probably not 40 seconds something
check check and overtake anyway check
you cannot play a 5 may be king of seven
or something like that i'm playing this
a little bit too too relaxed him to be
honest yeah yeah it's got that bloody
chicken and i didn't pay any attention
that was just terribly played black
resign in the game that I should never
have lost because he was worse all the
way I spent too long in this position
just making normal Musa and quick i er
there's no reason to be a to be down on
time in this kind of position and
besides the fact that I shouldn't just
simply win it I mean why detectable to a
three NT just resins that bloody game
and then sometimes I really don't know
what I'm doing there how can i play book
82 in this position it's super obvious
of course I can cover from the side and
this position is just a flat wing and
it's super easy I can go here and just
win this oh my god
now I have to end this session this is
just no use if you cannot do this kind
of thing I mean this is this is just
plain awful I mean of course I still
should not lose that sets clear but yeah
remarkable I have I just challenged and
played it in a check and hard to relaxed
fashion now this is this is now lost it
just terribly played but just just a
three I mean what am I doing here this
is the most the most depressing loss and
where the opponent who's supposed to be
a super strong player just does nothing
I mean he just plays a russian opening
and gets into a bad end game defends it
badly and I mean you could have defended
much better of course and then you play
like a complete idiot yeah and even lose
it I mean amazing amazing stuff and this
is so easy just amazing and it's still
here I mean I can still play rugby too
and play a two why not voluntarily and
why is he not I don't get it you should
of course play rugae for here that's
that's the only move instead you place
this nonsense and I can still play rugby
to win win amazing yeah I cannot win
anymore at least of course I still
shouldn't lose I think I can probably
draw with g5 or something like that it
should be pretty straightforward and
just didn't just stay here as this is
kind of poor information it's not I mean
he cannot move the King away as then I'm
checking him and I'm going to promote
the apron I should just go formed I
should have just like invested five
seconds and find
kind of drawing set up him maybe I would
have lost some time I don't know but
it's a I mean losing this is pretty
pretty ridiculous pretty ridiculous okay
thanks for watching